今回モンスターペアレントについて校調の意見を伺いたいんですけど。
はい。あ、はい。
まずモンスターペアレントっていうのは結構聞いたことありますか?
うん。うちもたくさん来たよ。うちは幸いにして効律じゃないし義務教育でもないからね。嫌ならやめとけって言うんや。うちに頼みに来る限りはうちの言うことをそのまま聞け。
で、あんたらができるんだったら、
ちゃんと意見を言えるんだったら、こ、
お前んとこみたいな子供ができるわけない
やないかい。そんな子供を作っておいて、
まだ自分の意見を言うというのは俺は
ふざけた話やで。うちでさえもそうなんだ
から。まししては学校義務教育の場ではね
、あ、言うよ。ただ自分が何を言っとるか
は分かってないやろ。マスコミに書いて
あることばっかりを言っとるんだ。その
通りのこと。
自分の考えなんかどこにもないよ。あいつらはね。
最近でちょっと話題になったやつだと
うん。
寝てる生徒に対して学校の先生がちょっと起きろってこうポンって
叩くか手を乗せるかした時にまそれが体罰って言って、
ま、保護者が乗り込んできて学校の先生が謝罪みたいな。うんうん。やめりゃええやん。だから学校側としてやならやめてくださいと言えばええんやん。うちはこういう風にやってますしそこへあんた方が入ってきた。
それが気にあんのやったらやめてくれ言っ
て要する転校すりゃええやないか。それが
言えんのが学校がダメなとこやないの。
自分たちはプロだ。プロが素人の言うこと
を聞くやつがあるか。
これ構造的にその保護者の方が学校よりも
強くなってしまってるっていうとこだと
思う。そういう風にしちまったわけやろ。
バカマスコミのおかげで。それは逆や。
教育してもらいたいの。そうじゃないの。
教育してもらいたいんなら黙って教育され
よ。引ったくのも教育の1つだ。あの
バカマスコミが。体罰は教育でない。体罰
をするのは法律違反で消しからん。
消しからんと言い続けたもんで。批判的に
権力者マスコミを見る能力のない親。
ほとんど母親やろ。それがマスコミの言う
通りの行動。ああ、私もここで言え
るってのもんやろね。自分たちはええこと
しとるつもりでおるんや。
これ和とかだとモンスターペアレントって言われるような人達っていなかったんですか?
初めはいなかったよね。だから後からリベラルがわけのわからんことばっかり言い出して強制してはいかんの。列を作らしてはいかんの。幼稚園は
100m競争は全員
手前で止まって手をついではい全員一しというあいうことをやらした世代の頃から始まったんやね。
それを作ったのは日教やで。日教がそう
いうことをやりそうな親に対して洗脳して
やね。で、やらしとるんや。左翼は悪い
ことばっかりやろ。必ず。なぜならば左翼
は悪だからや。それをマスコミは星は悪だ
けど左翼は善にしたやろ。で、そんなこと
になっちまった。
学校の先生からしたらモンスターペアイレントに対する対処ってもうどうしようもない部分も多いと思うんですよね。
できないやね。したら怒られるんね。あいつらの特徴用よ。必ず教育委員会とかマスコミに告げ口をするんやね。告口外交なんで韓国がやって嫌がらじゃん。日本は悪い国です。言ってアメリカに言いにくいや。あれと同じやね。
もっと先生よりも強いとこに対して、あの
先生は悪い先生ですと言いに行く。それの
言うことを聞かい
教育委員会だって言って文部省に言ってか
れるもんで、みんなもどっか途中で折れて
先生1人首にしときゃええやってのもんや
ね。で、そういうちゃんとした熱心な先生
をどんどん首にしていったやん。あれは
もう左翼の陰謀やで。
ま、母親が自分の子供が可愛くてちょっとそうなってしまうっていうのは、ま、一定仕方がないことだと思うんですけど
うん。
じゃ、この問題の根本的に悪いのは校調的にはこうどこが悪いみたいな風に考えてますか?
男女平等と称する女性上位が正しいと言い出したマスコミだ。だからお母さんたちは自分たちはも言ってもええんやと。も言ってはいかんよね。知らんのやもん。
教育側の方だと誰が悪いと思いますか?
それは文部省やろうな。文部省がマスコミに文句言われるもんで。だから教育委員会に対してこういう風にしろと言ってく。教育委員会が各学校にそいつを強制する。
番元は文部省や。文部省の連中が分かってない。教育とはなんか分かってないじゃん。仕事はかんの?強制はいかんのとああいうわけのわからんことばっかり言い出すんやね。
校長のコメント欄とか僕もスタッフとしてアカウントとか管理してると学校の先生の指示者がすごい多い印象あるんですけど、
これなんでなんですかね?
全部学校の先生のせいにされるからさ。マスコミのせいなんよね。マスコミの論長見てごらん。全て現場が悪いっていうのがマスコミの論長や。自分たちは現場じゃない。上から見とるんだから自分たちは悪くないと言いたいんや。あれがいかんのや。
日本がずっと例えば成長してきた、
あるいは日新戦争、日郎戦争で敵を
やっつけちまった。あれ全部現場が優れ
とったからじゃない?そうやね。そいつを
現場が優れとったというのはどうも気
に入らんのや。偏察修催どもは現場上やと
思っとる。現場はブルーから上はホワイト
からだと思っとんのね。そんなもんに
しがみついている限り現場を否定せんこと
にはなんか悪いことが起こった時失敗した
時に困るやろ。自分たちのせにされたら
いかんねん。だから現場結局彼らが言っ
てんのは子供を甘やかせと言っとるわけ
やろ。甘やかして投稿拒否ができるやろ。
そうしたら甘やかし方が足らんからだって
言い出すんや。そういうね現場でやった
ことのない人間最初から言っとるやろ。
気構強一知ってるということはできると
いうことだ。だけどああいう偉い人って
いうのはやったことないやないか、現場で
。だから何にも分かってない。何にも知ら
ん。その連中が判断せないかんねん。そし
たらなんかわけのわからん綺麗事ごとの
法則に乗っとって相手を否定するより
しょうがない。自分たちはそれを知っとる
。現場はそれを知らない。ダメな連中や
からね。
だから現場のせいだというもこれがずっと続いちまった。特に教育に関してね。
校長の安間の出演会とか見てると現場の人は賛成派が多いですけど
包といつもバチバチやってるの評価というか評論化側の人と相性が良くないことが多いです。
評論化なんて特に教育の評論家ってダメなのが多いよね。だって
[音楽]1
回日本の教育を潰しちまった連中やで。
その連中が偉そうなこと言ったらいかんの
や。平当してな。私たちが悪かったと言わ
ないいかんのに。まだ自分が正しいと言い
はるわけやろ。だからどうしても自分が
正しいということが認められる部分だけに
話を絞るやん。う論争する時は松明が松明
がしか言わんねん。も50
年前に言っとったことやで。
毎回出るためにあそこから話が始まって。
そっから話が始まってんで、そいつをなんとか本筋に戻そうとするともう時間が来ておしまいや。だから俺は安間に
回かそこらとるんだ。全然喋ってないよ。もそこで切れまう。それがあのバカマスコミのやることない。マスコミは自分たちの顔をるためには悪物でなくては困るんや。
だから必死になって悪物にする。寄って
たかってそれをする。あそこでアンチ凸と
して呼んでもらえる連中は新凸になったら
もう呼んでもらえへんからあくまでも曲の
意見を言うわね。
質問変えて、親御3
目線からだと、ま、学校が甘やかすような教育をだんだんちょっとそっちにシフトしていってると思うんですけど、自分の子供をしっかり育てたいっていう風に考えたらこうどうすればいいとかありますか?
から平等思想平等なんてことはありえんぞ。
番いいかんのはみんなを平等にすると平等に扱うと進歩しなくなるということや。そこに必ず差をつけんといかん。えいやつはこれは素晴らしい。
悪いやつ、お前ダメだと。で、この差を
つけることを霊と言うんだ。能力に差が
ある。その能力を正しく分かれ。自分の
まず能力をよくわかる。これがなみんな
できへんやないか。自分が素晴らしいもん
だと思っとのばっかりやん。そうすると
偉い人ははるかに上なんだということが
よくわかる。分かったらそこにその差に
よって恥をかける。恥が人間を進歩させる
。恥というのはそのためにあるんだ。それ
なのに子供に恥を欠かしてはいかんという
のが今の教育論。せっかく進歩に大事な恥
。こいつを子供から取り上げようという
ことや。だから子供は進歩線んのやないか
。落ちこぼりができちまう。進歩線からね
。こういう基本的な人間の性質全然分かっ
てないよね。ヨーロッパの精神論というの
は。で、どうしてかと言うと、神が人間を
作った想像論だから人間はみんな平等なん
やと。神が不良品を作るはずないやないか
。みんな平等なんだから平等に扱え。これ
が平等論やで。ちゃんっちゃおかしいやろ
。生まれた時から差があるよ。黒人と白人
だってさやろ。そいつを認めん。これが
リベラルだからおかしなことになるんや。
誰でも差は感じる。差を感じるからもっと
頑張って伸びようとする。あるいは下に
追いつかれんように自分も頑張ろうと上も
下も伸びていくわけだ。それがいいの悪い
の問題やないやないか。あるもの精神でも
肉体でも全部善に決まっとるやないか必要
だからあるんだ。それとね、最後に
ちょっと1つ言っとくとね、ショート動画
がしょっち流れるやろ。あれに関しては私
はチェックしてないから。で、それに
関する苦情は受け付けません。諸君があれ
を切って張り合しただけやからね。それを
1つコメントはね、こっちまで届かんから
。だからもしうちに対するコメント文句が
あるやろなあ。バカだバカだって言うんだ
から。だからそのコメントはとかヨット
スクールを支援する回というメールくれれ
ば時間があれば答えるし直接の方がよく
わかるからね。相手がどこが分からんかが
分かる。だからヨッスクルを支援する会の
方にメールをくれね。精神に関する色々
論争があるし、いろんなことを言う人が
おって、みんな自分が正しいと言うんだ
から。セミナー確実に奇数月に東京、
名古屋、大阪とやってるからもしそれに
参加したい人数に制限があるもんでヨット
スクールを支援する会塚ヨットスクールを
支援する回のホームページを見てもらえば
で、そこに申し込んでもらえば席は取り
ます。ただし満席になったらもうちょっと
勘弁願いたい。
あれはね、消防法によってそこの部屋の人数以上に入れてはいかんのだということをよろしく。
[音楽]
リンクも動画の概要欄にも記載します。